le casse du siècle pour l'instant les
égoutiers qui ont été arrêtés sont des
petits truands enquête parlementaire sur
les sociétés d'aéronautique les
socialistes voulaient la limiter à la
firme d'assaut le plan kissinger sur
l'avenir de la rhodésie discuté à genève
sans kissinger salon du prêt-à-porter
une nouvelle griffe la princesse de
bourbon-parme juan carlos à paris
portrait d'un roi qui règne qui gouverne
c'est le dossier le journal
mais là messieurs bonsoir un roi à paris
les badauds en ont pris l'habitude mais
d'un roi d'espagne en france
voilà qui est tout à fait nouveau
juancarlos arrivé depuis le début de
l'après-midi à paris est le premier
souverain espagnol a traversé
officiellement les pyrénées depuis 63
ans
si on excepte la rencontre pétain encore
à montpellier pendant l'occupation il
faut remonter à 1913 à la visite à paris
d'alphonse xiii
une visite qui ne va pas sans faire
grincer quelques dents à
l'extrême-gauche d'abord une
manifestation ce moment même à paris
à gauche tout court et puis du côté de
ceux qui s'inquiètent de
l'impressionnant dispositif de sécurité
quelques 3000 policiers ne reste pas
moins que l'événement est de taille il
consacre à l'intérieur une évolution du
régime et à l'extérieur le rapprochement
l'espagne vers le marché comme 15h cet
après midi à orly juan carlos 1er roi
d'espagne et la reine sophie ce n'est
pas leur première visite officielle à
l'étranger on les a vus aux états unis
en amérique latine mais c'est la
première en europe
48 heures en france à travers la
personne de juan carlos
c'est une nouvelle image que l'espagne
cherche à donner d'elle même celle de la
libéralisation
enfin dans le même élan de son peuple et
de son roi
le souffle du renouveau et de la liberté
c'est dire avec quel sentiment d'amitié
de confiance et d'espoir
la france salue votre arrivée cyr et se
réjouit
d'accueillir en la personne de ces
jeunes souverain l'espagne des temps
modernes entre cole habituel des chefs
d'état en visite officielle avec
pourtant cet aspect particulier des
liens d'amitié qui se sont créés entre
valéry giscard d'estaing et juan carlos
témoin les cadeaux offerts cet après
midi par le président français un
récepteur de navigation souverain
espagnol un dériveur à son fils philippe
et une chaîne fidélité à la reine sophie
témoin aussi c'est inhabituel le fait
que juan carlos visitera vendredi les
installations nucléaires dans le sud de
la france et c'est donc à paris que juan
carlos ghosn cherchait il aura deux
entretiens avec le président français la
caution qui permettra à l'espagne de
s'intégrer au marché comme un voyage
politique où seront à peine effleuré les
relations économiques entre paris et
madrid
la france reste le premier client de
l'espagne et son quatrième fournisseur
les où l'on parlera sans doute beaucoup
de l'europe la france petit trouver son
intérêt
les partenaires du marché commun aussi
pour que l'espagne ne se tournent pas
exclusivement vers les états unis et
nous revenons fans journal sur cet
événement avec notre dossier un portrait
de juan carlos par polna les aveux des
preuves
l' enquête des policiers après le coup
de filet qui leur a permis de mettre la
main sur quelques uns des auteurs du
fric rade de nice à ce soir
considérablement progressé à tel point
que cette gangue ster vienne d'ores et
déjà d'être déféré au parquet de nice
pour les policiers vous le savez ce
n'est qu'un demi succès ou même un tir
de succès puisque ils ont chiffré les
effectifs du gang à 25 personnes
ils sont même furieux car l' annonce
prématurée de leur coup de filet a
permis à certains de prendre la fuite
et c'est dommage car après quatre mois
d'enquêté il était sur le point de
coffrets toute la bande
coffret si j'ose dire s'agissant du hold
up de la société générale
cela dit une belle pêche quand même
qu'entre les malfaiteurs qui seront
présentés demain au magistrat
instructeur
nous avons réuni les preuves matérielles
dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure
c'est à dire la possession de billets
provenant
du vol à la société générale de nice et
la négociation de lingots d'or qui ont
été également volé à la société générale
de nice lingot d'or qui est fait en
cours de négociation ou qui avait déjà
été négocié de plus certaines des
déclarations des personnes impliquées
nous apporte des lumières sur les
conditions du cambriolage je ne peux
décemment vous en dire plus là dessus
puisque aussi bien jeu govou c'est vous
signaler que vous savez les
investigations se poursuivent et qui
n'est pas exclu que de nouvelles
arrestations importantes aient lieu dans
les prochaines heures c'est clair tous
les gangsters ayant participé au
cambriolage n'ont donc pas été arrêté et
honoré gévaudan se garde bien de dire
que plus de 20 personnes ont participé
au casse de nice
quant au butin il n'a été qu'en partie
récupérer ce qui est sûr c'est que deux
des instigateurs sont inculpés près
pellegrin et bournat que le troisième
vingt d'y être arrêté à nice que le
quatrième enfin est en fuite
c'est lui qui a constitué la bande mais
la police connaît parfaitement son
identité reste et d'histoire courant
juin un ancien commerçant de nice devenu
truand celui qui a été arrêté
précisément à nice d'un appel grains à
bournat des informations sur la société
générale
l'emplacement des coffres l'épaisseur
des murs pellegrin et bournat ne peuvent
pas faire le coup seuls ils vont voir un
troisième truands celui que l'on
recherche
et qu'a constitué la bande plus de 20
personnes
le pouvaient monter le matériel et
achetés dans dix villes différentes
et tandis que les truands ont commencé
les travaux dans les goûts cinq d'entre
eux sont interpellés un soir par hasard
par la gendarmerie et par la sûreté
urbaine qui relèvent leur identité est
trouvé dans le coffre de leur voiture
des burins mais ça n'est que plus tard
le lendemain de la découverte du vol à
nice que les gendarmes et la sûreté
urbaine préviendront la police
judiciaire qui connaît donc pratiquement
tout de suite
certes un gangster alors deux questions
pourquoi les gangsters ne sont ils pas
s'arrêter tout de suite ça n'était que
des exécutants m'a dit un policier
il nous fallait les têtes et puis il
nous fallait des preuves formelles
deuxième question pourquoi certains
truands se sachant repérés par la
gendarmerie et par la sûreté ont ils
continué le casse ce sont des mythes eu
des petits m'a dit d'un autre policier
voilà des propos qui démystifie bien ce
que l'on a appelé le casse du siècle
c'est donc fait dès que l'ensemble des
députés auront donné leur feu vert une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire va
donc se pencher sur les activités de
monsieur marcel dassault est à société
en fait c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué ça car le rapporteur de la
commission des lois jacques limouzy a
souhaité étendre l'enquète à l'ensemble
de l'industrie aéronautique ce qui a
provoqué l'abstention les communistes et
le vote négatif des socialistes qui
estimait qu'à sion ont noyé le poisson
dans l'eau les restaurateurs eux sont
même allés d'ores et déjà plus loin par
les voix de max lejeune et de
jean-jacques servan-schreiber ils ont
souhaité une prise de participation de
l'état dans l'ensemble aéronautique
français quant au premier ministre lui
il a repoussé le principe d'une
nationalisation de cet ensemble nous
écoutons son point de vue mais d'abord
celui de monsieur limouzy non je ne vois
pas le poid soeur je vous dis que j'ai
dans ma proposition à toutes les
affaires citées dans le rapport de la
cour des comptes lui même cité par
monsieur de faire un grand effort
justement pourquoi est ce que monsieur
dassault peut rentrer dans cet ensemble
de l'aéronautique
parce que ce parce qu'il y a un système
qui est justement critiqué d'ailleurs
actuellement d'avancés remboursables
notamment qui s'applique à d'autres
sociétés que lui-même et qu'il faut voir
exactement s'il ya des retards dans le
remboursement qui remboursent ce qu'ils
ont remboursés par qu'est ce qu'on fait
de l'argent éventuellement qui n'est pas
remboursé c'est ça le problème
personne n'ignore d'ailleurs que la
commission se préoccupera
prioritairement de monsieur dassault
père c'est la question posée mais le
travail n'est pas possible
lisez le rapport de la cour des comptes
sur l'envisagé pas les choses d'une
manière plus large afin de porter un
diagnostic plus précis justement cet
après midi à l'assemblée le premier
ministre a ainsi répondu à monsieur
villon communiste qui réclamait la
nationalisation de dassault et de toute
l'industrie aérospatiale sur le fond je
vous indique fait simplement que la
philosophie du gouvernement n'est pas
particulièrement orientée
la formule de la nationalisation sûr je
suis et 1.2 principe général je crois
voilà j'ai retenu à votre intention
toute une série de nouvelles brèves et
d'abord celle ci qui intéresse tous les
automobilistes et dieu sait s'ils sont
nombreux du long pont de la toussaint le
super à 225 c'est pour bientôt mais pas
comme on l'avait dit avant le 3 novembre
sachez aussi que le conseil des
ministres a retenu le principe de
l'instauration d'un bilan social dans
les entreprises depuis trois mille cinq
cents salariés ou est un petit peu
analogue au bilan financier bilan annuel
du aussi que robert fabre et michel deux
bâtisses se sont rencontrés ce matin
pour confronter notamment les positions
de la fnsea et des radicaux de gauche en
matière d'indemnisation de la sécheresse
et puis que le franc et la livre ont
encore eu quelques faiblesses ce matin
sur les marchés européens
à tel point que la rumeur d'une
démission du cabinet callaghan a même
couru cet après-mid vie qu'en fait nous
disons de l'anniversaire monsieur
mitterrand ans au mythe errant qui en
effet a soufflé 60 bougies ce matin à
jérusalem
il est pour l'instant en voyage d'étude
en israël où il s'est déclaré en
désaccord avec certains aspects de la
politique française au proche orient
une fois de plus geneve redéploie ses
tapis vert pour tenter d'harmoniser ses
points de vue mais dans le cas qui nous
intéresse
l'ouverture demain la conférence sur la
rhodésie c'est plutôt de damier ou
d'échiquier qu'il faudrait parler des
blancs et des noirs d'un côté les
anglais et les rhodésiens blanc de
l'autre les nationalistes africains les
chances de réussite sans le docteur
miracle
l'américain qui suggère évalué soupesée
par claude carré ce soir chaque
délégation campe sur ses positions
aucune ne veut céder le moindre pouce de
terrain et la négociation qui doit
s'ouvrir demain ici à genève semble
incertaine la côte et le premier
ministre désigné jan smith il est venu
ici à genève contraint et forcé par le
plan kissinger
il veut donc essayer de préserver au
maximum le pouvoir blanc son but c'est
dès le moins possible et le plus tard
possible
de l'autre les noirs nationalistes comme
ici les plus durs
johan comoé robert mugabe le chef de la
guérilla veulent tout tout de suite
les multiples délégations noire il y a
plus de 200 délégués à genève temps
d'oublier leurs querelles et leurs
divisions sur les conseils des pays
socialistes voisin de la rhodésie le
mozambique la tanzanie par exemple ils
sont devenus intransigeant car ils
savent qu'ils ont le vent en poupe le
plan kissinger distiller des passes et
nous ne voulons plus discuté d'un
gouvernement intérimaire multiraciales
en rhodésie et d'un pouvoir noir dans
deux ans il faut dès maintenant négocier
la passation des pouvoirs
le malentendu est donc complet et la
grande bretagne qui préside cette
conférence est bien ennuyé car elle a
d'autres problèmes aussi urgents
la chute de la livre par exemple autres
conférences qui détermine mais à
beaucoup plus long terme l'avenir de l'
équilibre mondial
la réunion du club de rome contrairement
à ce que l'on peut croire de prime abord
le club de rome ce n'est pas une aimable
assemblée de gentleman qui se contentent
de brasser des idées en l'air
fondée comme son nom l'indiqué à rome le
club tient réunion depuis hier à alger
en présence aujourd'hui du président
boumédiène présence silencieuse mais
attentive au milieu de 300 personnalités
politiques universitaires venus des
quatre continents pour mettre au point
une plateforme commune sur le nouvel
ordre économique international
jusqu'à lors le club de rome publier des
rapports en général assez inquiétant sur
l'avenir du club
aujourd'hui les congressistes veulent
concrétiser toutes leurs idées et faire
au gouvernement des propositions
précises
la guerre économique est sur le point
d'éclater entre le japon et l'europe le
japon brade ses prix en laye des marchés
dans le monde entier et de ce fait prive
de ressources des dizaines de milliers
de travailleurs européens dans deux mois
sans doute les pays exportateurs de
pétrole ont relevé les tarifs qu'ils
imposent à leurs clients décision qui
peut être lourde de conséquences pour
les économies de certains pays européens
comme la france déjà en mauvaise posture
en six mois le prix du café a augmenté
de 100 % tandis que s'effondrer le prix
du phosphate aucun rapport entre ces
deux produits saute que les plantations
anarchique de leurs cours illustrent le
désordre qui règne sur le marché
international des matières premières
agricoles et minéral désordre qui
perturbe les économies des pays sous
développés comme celle des pays
industriels pour des raisons
métres allemands opposés mais aux effets
similaires pendant ce temps là la course
aux armements continue ruinant les pays
pauvres à tel point qu'on a calculé
qu'en 50 ans l'argent consacré aux armes
six mille milliards de dollars 1976
aurait pu faire disparaître à jamais la
faim dans le monde
bref le globe dont la population
s'accroît dont les ressources s'épuisent
dont les océans se pollue poursuit
imperturbablement sa marche chaotique et
aveugle depuis quatre ans une équipe
d'hommes lucide tendent d'infléchir
cette trajectoire
c'est ce club de rome d'alger où il est
réunie lance aujourd'hui un nouveau cri
d'alarmé
faute d'un accord international rapide
du type de celui qui devrait n'être de
la conférence nord sud réunis à
l'initiative de la france
nous allons au drame prédiction fondée
sur des données
apparemment irréfutables je doute
cependant qu'elle empêche quelqu'un de
dormir cette nuit
après nous le déluge
voulez-vous être indépendant ou préférez
vous restez français c'est la question
qui sera posée dans plus de six mois aux
habitants du territoire français des
afars et des issas autrement dit
djibouti le conseil des ministres a en
effet adopté ce matin le projet de loi
qui fixe les modalités de ce prochain
référendum projet de loi que le
gouvernement voudrait voir voté au plus
vite par le parlement
c'est à dire au cours de la pression
présente session parlementaire
le 8e sommet arabe est un succès a dit
mahmoud ryad le secrétaire général de la
ligue arabe
en guise de conclusion de la réunion du
caire succès peut-être mais mahmoud ryad
a bien eu du mal quand même à expliquer
pourquoi
rien ou pratiquement rien de nouveau n'a
été décidé les chefs d'état arabes ont
simplement approuvé les décisions du
précédent sommet à savoir l'envoi de 30
mille hommes au liban aucune réponse par
contre à ces questions importantes qui
va envoyer des soldats qui va payer
cette opération comment vont ils s'y
prendre pour rétablir l'ordre
un aspect positif quand même le
cessez-le-feu est pour l'instant
respecté au liban il est normal qu'un
prêtre travail
il est normal qu'un prêtre se marie par
contre il n'est pas normal qu'un prêtre
s'engage dans un parti politique c'est
ce qui ressort d'un sondage réalisé par
la sofres et publiée dans l'hebdomadaire
le pèlerin à propos de l'image du prêtre
chez les français un sondage sur lequel
naturellement les évêques réunis pendant
trois jours encore à lourdes ne manquons
pas de réfléchir
autre élément de réflexion un livre
blanc que l'écrivain michel de saint
pierre vient de remettre à l'assemblée
des évêques
il contient des doléances des
catholiques traditionalistes première
chirurgicale pour le docteur dubernard
de l'hôpital edouard herriot de lyon
avec la greffe d'un pancréas
originalité de cette opération très
délicate qui avait déjà été tentée à
travers le monde mais sans succès cette
fois les chirurgiens ont transplanté
seulement la partie interne de l'organe
c'est à dire celle secrétan l'insuline
et si cette nouvelle technique donne
satisfaction elle devrait soulager
essentiellement les grands diabétiques
et devrait permettre aussi de pratiquer
dans certains cas la greffe du rein
ces deux informations sportives tout à
fait étonnante à vous livrer d'abord
vous tout skieur apprenez que sur les
pistes comme sur les routes
vous n'aurez plus le droit de dépasser
le 110 km heure c'est surtout valable
pour les champions qui parfois friser
les 140
c'est une décision très sérieuse de la
fédération internationale de ski et puis
ce coup de filet encore un dans les
milieux du cyclisme car c'est un coup
très dur que la fédération française de
cyclisme a porté aux organes dopage qui
sévissent et chez les coureurs de
lourdes amendes et suspensions qui vont
jusqu'à deux ans ferme
voilà qui va faire du bruit et si les
huit coureurs incriminés ne sont pas
tous très connu vous savez sans doute
par exemple qui est dit sybille champion
de france professionnel depuis samedi et
pour quelques jours encore
encore un salon le salon de ce que les
quelque cinquante mille visiteurs
professionnels appellent tous et je m'en
excuse le salon de la fringue
traduction le salon du prêt-à-porter et
parallèlement à l'autre bout de paris la
semaine du vêtement féminin
bref deux occasions pour vous frotter un
peu aux soieries aux draps aux fonds
faux et pour vous confier dans le creux
de l'oreille que la mode est aux robes
fendues hausse forte aux robes sacs au
style paysans ou exotiques et que parmi
les papas et les mamans des collections
à venir deux intrus une star et une
pincée
au 32e salon du prêt à porter ont 100
exposants venus de 29 pays propose 150 à
200 milles modèles qui seront achetés
par 47 mille visiteurs venus commandes
et les robes que les femmes porteront
neuf mois plus tard
parmi ces exposants de nouveau label
celui de brigitte bardot qui sous le
signe de la madrague propose des robes à
la fois enfantine et provocante
correspondant bien à son image de marque
et qui sont présentées par des
mannequins qui lui ressemble et celui du
prince andré de bourbourg parme dont la
femme marina et la modéliste
j'ai toujours des mirob
on a beau y toujours
ou alors je me suis habillé avec des
chiffons que j'ai fondu moi-même et
antiquaires décorateur et ça ça
m'amusait beaucoup et j'ai eu à ces jeux
vous lu des choses un peu plus propre
vous portez uniquement forum oui
principalement
je n'ose pas rentrer dans une autre
boutique parce que c'est pas qu'il n'y a
rien qui me plaisent mais je ne je ne
trouve rien qui corresponde année
les idées chocs du salon ne sont
sûrement pas celle de marina de bourbon
parme qui meublent as oblige crée des
robes dont genre ce ne sont que short
long cours serré ou larges parfois caché
par une jupe
pantalon de zouaves de clowns ou de
sultan
car on sera exotique de la sultana la
pêcheuse de perles le moyen et l'extrême
orient sont appelés à la rescousse avec
l'afrique et l'océanie
ou bien retour à la terre on sera les
deux tiers aux jardinières avec jupe on
est fichu style broussard et gitane pour
les tissus légères et fluides ou la
toile haber déchiré effiloché
car pour être dans le vent il faudra le
laisser passer le vent par des fentes
modestes ou provocante et tous ces
courants d'air ventilant 6 milliards et
demi de chiffre d'affaires à quand le
prêt à porter signé par un académicien
ou un prix nobel par donné
l'enchaînement mais quand on apprend
plus que le couturier saint laurent m
les femmes à l'heure espagnole avec des
oeillades des corses les de velours des
chalets ghazi des bas noirs et des
peines dans le chignon bas on est obligé
de revenir à l'événement numéro un de la
journée la visite de juan carlos à paris
juan carlos à qui le présent à public
vient d'offrir tout à l'heure un cadeau
insolite un récepteur de navigation ce
qui nous permet de savoir que le roi
aime la voile mais à part ça
que savons nous de cet homme
incroyablement discret qui longtemps a
vécu dans l'ombre déformante de son
parrain spirituel franco et bien
finalement peu de choses sur sa
personnalité profonde sur ses véritables
intentions politiques
ce dossier va essayer nous offrir un
portrait plus approcher le palais royal
près de madrid c'est ici que vit un
jeune roi de 38 ans
juancarlos assume depuis un an l'une des
successions les plus difficiles celle de
franco le vieux dictateur qui a gouverné
l'espagne jusqu'à son dernier souffle
mais aujourd'hui le style a changé
juan carlos roi d'espagne descendant de
louis xiv de fernand 7 d'isabelle la
catholique et d'alphonse xiii mais qui
juan carlos le fils spirituel de franco
et il son image vivante qui se reflète
encore dans le miroir du franquisme
ou tout simplement un jeune chef d'état
qui doit à tout prix faire oublier les
démons du passé
le prince a vécu pendant six ans dans
l'ombre désigné officiellement en 1969
comme successeur de franco
juan carlos est peu à peu associés aux
fastes et aux pontes du régime
mais jamais le prince de céder partie de
la prudence et du masque ambiguë les
bourbes faites vous connaître
c'est ce que franco lui commandent le
prince voyage alors beaucoup surtout en
espagne dans toutes les provinces qui
sont la réalité profonde du pays espagne
et je tâche de pénétrer chaque jour
davantage dans un véritable intimité
si je ne me ferai pas jour après jour à
mieux connaître cette réalité de
l'espagne je manquerais à mon obligation
soyez certains que par tous les moyens
je m'emploie non seulement à la
connaître mes amants pénétrait
totalement la mort de l'amiral carrero
blanco poutre maîtresse du régime et
bras droit
quant aux constituants du tournant
politique majeur du pays juancarlos
assistent aux obsèques il représente le
pouvoir et il sait l'espagne en pierre
c'est que l'heure du prince approche il
faudra aussi compter avec ceux qui
pendant tout le parcours funèbres dont
le salut fasciste et ils sont des
milliers également à molester les
évêques espagnols jugé trop riche
c'est aussi cela la réalité politique en
espagne l'opposition se taire
l'assassinât de carrero blanco
c'est un peu la première mort du général
franco deux ans de rumeurs sur la
maladie du car audio un vieillard qui
n'en finit plus de mourir
pourquoi de carlos le jour de l'annoncé
officielle de la mort c'est la
délivrance
il gouverne désormais seul mais le roi
doit aussi tourner la page et aller très
vite
d'abord assuré l'armée qui a été et qui
reste encore l'un des piliers du système
flatté et donner des assurances aux
ultras du régime l'opposition elle
demande des preuves concrètes de
libéralisation points de carlos est prêt
à démocratiser l'espagne accordez-moi
six mois seulement
menti à ceux qui le pressent devant les
cortès juancarlos de nouveau roi a prêté
serment en coulisses les grandes
manoeuvres politiques continuent et
différentes oppositions profite de la
cérémonie de couronnement pour se réunir
aux quatre coins du pays
points de carlos a déjà préparé avec ses
conseillers les lois d'amnistié premier
pas concret vers une démocratisation de
l'espace l'espagne de juan carlos et
arriérée politiquement les chefs d'état
du monde et d'europe qui assistent
cérémonie attentes
eux aussi des gestes de bonne volonté
car madrid veut rejoindre le marché
comme pourtant encore en espagne le
droit d'association n'existe pas le
parti communiste est hors la loi pas de
droit de grève pas droit de
manifestation
pas de suffrage universel et le régime
est une monarchie
le sentiment monarchique n'a jamais
cessé d'exister dans le pays le marché
devrait être un régime efficace qui doit
assurer la paix et le bien-être de tous
les espagnols juan carlos n'est pas
franco le style a radicalement changé
la transition s'est faite sans heurts
l'espagne réellement sur la voie
démocratique qui pouvait le croire il y
a tout juste un an
et puisque nous parlons en voyage
officiel un petit mot sur la visite de
valéry giscard d'estaing prévu la visite
en yougoslavie prévu le mois dernier et
reportée elle aura finalement lieu dans
la première quinzaine de décembre
voilà comme chaque jour à la même heure
la météo est toujours le même temps
d'automne ciel couvert l'ensemble du
pays des pluies sur la corse et les
alpes et puis les températures un peu
plus basque aujourd'hui dans l'est votre
prochain rendez vous à l'actualité dans
moins d'une heure avec notre magazine
c'est à dire présenté par jean marie
cavada grand témoin le professeur jacob
mais aussi deux séquences consacrées à
l'espagne avec le voyage de juan carlos
et puis à lourdes
l'assemblée des évêques au long de toute
la rédaction d'antenne 2 je souhaite à
tous une excellente soirée puis si vous
avez pris ce journal en cours de route
rappelle dit
c'est égoutiers du fric frac du siècle
de nice arrêtez ce ne sont que des
petits truands enquête parlementaire sur
les sociétés d'aéronautique le
gouvernement n'est pas favorable à la
nationalisation première chirurgicale à
lyon la grève d'un pancréas un espoir
pour les diabétiques visite officielle
en france du roi juan carlos valéry
giscard d'estaing salue le renouveau des
libertés vers 22h55 la dernière édition
du journal d'antenne 2